he's bossed up
yo he's bossed up and how's he bossed up
you ever heard of original grain dude
he's bossed up look at that
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by original grain
father's day is around the corner and
i've got some ideas for you from our
good friends at original green and i'm
wearing two of them check it out check
it out he's bossed up
use code congrats at originalgrain.com
to get 30 percent off of the most
fashionable watches made from reclaimed
whiskey barrels beer barrels exotic
woods and even taylor guitars you're
guaranteed to find something that fits
your style i did
and they make the perfect gift all right
let original grain do the heavy lifting
and go to
originalgrain.com original grain plants
a tree also for every watch they sell
and uh if you don't like it they'll buy
it back for you from you so
it's like a win-win you know and you're
a good person because they're playing a
tree you're helping the environment but
check this out dude look at that
look at that it's a nice color you wear
that with a nice suit or just relaxing
with like a cool shirt kind of the same
shade and the sunglasses imagine me
rolling by in a car just looking
dude that could be you with the eyebrow
activated forget it man
i love these sunglasses anyway uh
they've been making watches from unique
materials for almost a decade so where
you been huh where you been
they've got over 20 000 5 star reviews
check that out use code congrats at
originalgrain.com slash congrats to get
30
off
site wide um so yeah they also make
awesome wedding rings you know your boy
needs one of those
um
look at that sunglasses they got apple
watch bands it's all just go over to
originalgrain.com
and make sure you you'd co use code
congrats for 30
off
originalgrain.com to support the podcast
[Music]
three
two
[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
so i ate burgers last night well
you know and before we really even get
to it
um
let's do like my [ __ ] you know
if uh you're not subscribed subscribe to
the podcast and subscribe to the page we
got lifeline on this thing too and we
got more podcasts coming dude we're
gonna keep doubling until they kill me
and um we're also i'm going to be in
lots of different uh areas right because
i'm doing a tour i'm going to be in
lakeland florida i'm going to be in
grand prairie texas and that's going to
be in uh that's the dallas place so if
you're in dallas grand prairie texas not
too far
atlanta georgia washington dc stockton
california oakland california those are
all in september actually the dallas
date or the grand prairie texas date is
in
august
peoria illinois rockford illinois
october 7th and 8th
raleigh
north carolina october 21st october 22nd
savannah georgia
denver colorado at the bellco theater
november 5th november 6th to cheyenne
wyoming and november 12th two shows at
the wang theater in boston
and jacksonville florida december 3rd
those are the ones we have so far many
coming up after that but those are the
ones we're having coming up so far
so
that's it
and um
you know come on out crystalia.com the
tickets are going some of them are near
sellout they're some very big places so
you know your boy keeps moving your boy
keeps moving so um this is episode i
don't even know what the last episode of
congratulations was the patreon episode
and if you ever want to sign up for the
patreon there's about 14 patreon
episodes right now
that uh if you sign up today you get
access to them immediately you just
binge them like it's breaking bad if you
want
they're like you know
that would be like
breaking bad but more methy
and um and you can do that but the last
patreon episode was one of the best
episodes it was just
it was just a very special episode so if
you want to sign up to uh the patreon go
out over to patreon.comcrystalia
and uh binge that [ __ ] like it's [ __ ]
like it's breaking binge that [ __ ] like
it's the show servant like you're trying
to figure it out but you never really
figure it out even though even though
you're at the end of the third season
you're still trying to figure it out and
it never [ __ ] gets to figuring it out
because it's an m night shyamalan thing
and it's just convoluted baby that's
what it is man my shit's convoluted
congratulations it's convoluted you got
to do it in order though you know you
don't want to get lost um
so yeah had two burgers last night
oh my god yeah he did it he had two
burgers you know what he did
he goes like this
i'm gonna go he goes like this to
kristen i'm gonna go to the i'm gonna go
to the haha cafe she says you're gonna
go up i say maybe
she says oh okay
i leave to go to the haha cafe and
immediately
i get into
uh
if all of a sudden maybe it's a chemical
thing but bada bing
sadness comes over my whole body for no
reason not sad about anything just kind
of [ __ ] sweeps along like it's a
chemical like it was the happening like
it was nature or some [ __ ]
like the [ __ ] like instead of
making humans want to kill each other
speaking of
m night shyamalan with the movie the
happening let's keep along with the
theme of night shyamalan
now all of a sudden
it's like [ __ ] just a swoosh of of of
sadness
and um and all of a sudden he's sad and
it's maybe a chemical thing because he
doesn't really know what it is and yeah
he's good with his therapy and he's nice
checking in with his group
but has no idea why he's sad there's no
reason to be sad it's [ __ ] sunday
night memorial day shits is the next day
should be happy but he's not and he's
driving to the haha cafe
and he's sitting in so much blood but
he's driving to the haha cafe and he's
wondering why he's sad
anything should i even go why am i even
going to the haha cafe if i'm maybe not
going to go up i just want to get out of
the house you know calvin's down for the
for the for the he's going to sleep
and uh
and i don't know
and i uh
and i think you know what i want burgers
i want burgers but instead of going to
get burgers i still go to the haha cafe
and i text kristen do you want to get
burgers later and she says nope
he actually said nah which is the rudest
[ __ ] you could possibly text no matter
what you're talking about
especially like i'm trying to do
something nice hey you feel like having
some burgers i might order them for you
nah
so rude to type nah that's like the the
only more rude than nah is ha
if you do a joke you make fun of
somebody and they write ha
forget it
oh you [ __ ] you're my mortal enemy
right how about that shirt
that they [ __ ] try to sell with uh
what's her name uh uh rosa parks that
just goes nah rosa parks like she was
like she was in the back of the bus
going nah
you know like she wasn't scared for her
life but still making a point but still
making a stand which is great but when
you're standing
boy if you were standing if you were in
fear of your life but still making a
point and making a stand and you just
went nah dude the [ __ ] cojones on you
you know
the cojones on you so big you could just
sit on them like one of those [ __ ]
things that uh they sell in toy stores
that you just bounce around on the
aisles till they get mad at you but you
never buy
um
so
i say you want burger she goes nah
kristen 2022
and i'm like all right fine
so i go to haha
and i think let me wait this burger
thing out you know let me [ __ ] just
wait it out cause i bet she's cause i
what i did is i i planted the seed right
i planted the little meat seed didn't i
yeah i planted a little [ __ ] meat
seeding her it's like uh
in inception she's on her way falling
she's on her way in the [ __ ] bus with
me her and chenzo cause he's gonna eat
the [ __ ] rappers when we leave the
burgers out me her and chenzo just
falling in the bus backwards into the
[ __ ] river in the it's in the it's in
in [ __ ] burger section
and i [ __ ] planted the meat seed
didn't i
so i go let me wait this out i'm gonna
wait at the haha cafe i'm gonna meet
some friends i got there there were some
friends there and we hung out we had a
good time you know chilling with some
homies
and uh i hang there for about an hour
hour and a half i come back and what did
i do dude i hit her up about the burgers
yo baby i'm gonna get some burgers what
do you think and she says we're gonna
get it i sent her a link to a burger
place that was nice dude it wasn't no
burger king and i know i love in and out
but you know it wasn't even in and out
it was like some [ __ ] new place that
was popping up
and she goes uh what place i sent her
the link and she goes like this you know
what get me some fries and i wait
i'd chill cause i planted the seed and
she's just about to hit that water she's
just about to hit that water with me i'm
in with her dude i planted that meat
seat and i'm just about to feel
the back seat of that van
rush up against my spine
and the [ __ ] water's about to just
flood inside the back windows
and [ __ ] push chens and her up
against me and we'll get about to take a
deep breath because we gotta hold it
right
and i see those little dot dot dots come
in and she and then i see
and it says and get me a classic burger
he wins
he planted the meat seed and it sprouted
into a beautiful meal with his girl
[Music]
so i ate two burgers last night and as
soon as i ate them i regretted it yes no
they were [ __ ] so i mean it was so
disgusting it was like i swallowed some
lead ah yes dude
i mean it felt like there was so much
lead inside me superman couldn't see
what's behind me ah yes it was
disgusting
oh [ __ ] yeah man
oh it was so good
i'm with superman and there's a ninja
attacking me from behind and guess what
his sword goes right through my abdomen
and superman couldn't even [ __ ] warn
me because it was like i ain't letting
yes dude
and i go superman how could you betray
me but the thing i think of right before
i die is oh yeah the burgers and that's
my last words oh yeah
oh yeah the burgers to superman
yes dude superman can't see through
letty explains
his jokes
he's a dork but he's [ __ ] true to
himself what are you gonna do dude he's
so true to himself it's unbelievable
so i woke up [ __ ] stomach all clumped
up had some [ __ ] coffee it's still
right here only drank half of it and
johnny shits a lot in about an hour and
a half
oh yeah but he's been taking his [ __ ]
music so that's it's going to come out
real nice disgusting but it's fine
because i keep true to myself don't i
right
[ __ ] yeah dude
what about this though huh i almost wore
this but it's too hot in here but god
damn but the [ __ ] life rips with the
puff [ __ ] are you kidding me dude with
the puff [ __ ] are you kidding me i was
gonna wear this but it's too [ __ ] hot
and
crystallia.com going over get that puff
[ __ ]
um
so yeah man life's been good you know
i've been hanging out my son made me
smell a [ __ ] lemon this morning for
you know about 25 times
uh sons and daughters they make you do
so many [ __ ] things like that so over
and over again he goes like this hey
dadda smell the yemen i put the yemen in
the trash can puts it in his little
trash can that you we have a little
trash can that he plays with so much
it's just a trash can that you're
keeping like a [ __ ]
like like a a bathroom like right next
to it those those those trash cans suck
by the way like don't ever have a little
trash can you got to take it out 900
times in one day you throw [ __ ] a
piece of kleenex away and a capri sun
and you're like okay gotta take the
trash out
and then he just he had it though and he
just he took a lemon off the lemon tree
and for some reason kristin
is convinced it's a lime tree
it they're yellow and big and smell like
lemons and she's like you know they're
actually limes and i'm i just got to be
like like it's one of those [ __ ]
arguments where you're just like yeah
well but you know
it's like literally pointing to a duck
and being like that's a will you know
it's a woolly mammoth
if you'd like she'll be like if you just
if we kept them on the tree they turned
into limes and i'm just like
oh
oh
you're just gonna be a crazy person
but they're so yellow and when you
squeeze them and put them in a [ __ ]
water it's nice in the summer
and she's like yeah but if you just left
and i go oh
oh
that's as far as i go with this argument
if you're gonna point at something and
tell me it's something it's not i'm done
dude
i'm all done
right
hey chris you what are you wearing a
t-shirt no that's a sweater really
no this is a [ __ ] t-shirt no it's a
sweater
jumping out the plane [ __ ]
you know
like all right dude okay it's a lime yay
let's squeeze these yellow limes
in our drinks so calvin even calvin is
like it's a yemen like he knows dude
he says lemon like it's a [ __ ]
african country it's a yemen he can't
say zel's it's so cute yemen is a yemen
smell the yemen and i smell it oh yeah
and then he's like i put the yemen in
the tascam puts it in the trash can and
then picks it back up smell the yemen
again
and i'm like okay
put the yemen in the cash can put he
starts saying cash can
like it's a game show
and then picks it back up put the smell
the yemen okay it's not the yemen again
i smelled it so many times until i was
like you know what maybe this is a lime
i have no [ __ ] idea i don't even
smell it anymore i got past the point of
like it was like it was so
lemony that i wanted to like [ __ ]
vomit and he's just like you smelled the
yemen again and i smelled it 25 times
and then he just took the yemen and he
says the lemon and he says i throat the
yemen and through it and he says i'll go
get it yeah this and goes and gets it
and then comes back then he threw it 25
times and then it [ __ ] squirted open
because it's a [ __ ] yemen dude
and he's and he comes back and he's like
it's all wet it's all yet
it's yeah right here and i like we can't
throw it anymore
you know
[Music]
kristin's coming down like oh does he
have the lime and i'm just like all
right okay
yeah
my life
he's got to pretend lemons or limes
um
so anyway dude it's beautiful though man
he's learning words and [ __ ]
made me smell a lemon so many times it's
it's it's amazing what fatherhood will
make you do you'll just be sitting there
smelling a lemon 900 times like you're
in a [ __ ] like you're a mental patient
you know
um yemen is in the middle east i know
guys i know you know i just [ __ ] up
and i said africa and whatever it's like
it's not if it's not in america it's
anywhere like i watched a [ __ ]
serious and i know that's so [ __ ]
narrow-minded but i watched the thing on
uh broadmoor the insane asylum in
[ __ ] i don't even know where i think
it's in britain because the guy was
talking like he was britain but he was
also talking like he was
scottish so i'm like it could be an
anarcho for all i know it could be full
of [ __ ] penguins just crazy [ __ ]
serial killer penguins i have no idea i
think it's in europe but broadmoor
and it's just this i was watching this
documentary do it and it's insane man
the way that britain uh broadmoor the
way broadmoor
was like made in like the 18th or i
guess it would be the 17th century it's
19th century 1800 something
and they were like so [ __ ] uh
broadmoor was uh so
like they used to think like pyromaniacs
were the most
were the most dangerous people like even
more than serial killers and [ __ ] and
that they were the most criminally
insane and if you think about that now
that's insane but then if you think
about it back then you're like you know
what dude fire was [ __ ] probably out
of control back then
like there's all this [ __ ] fire
retardant [ __ ] right now 2022 if you
light a match in a building you're gonna
be fine even if you light some papers on
fire the [ __ ] sprinklers are gonna
come over
and [ __ ] it's going to be fine you
get a fire extinguisher shoot it out but
in the 1800s dude you light a match
it's a you're gone dude first of all hay
was everywhere you know
and like nobody knew anything about
anything fire retardant so they were
just walking around all dry and [ __ ]
and just lighting a flame would be
so so pyromaniacs were like
locked the [ __ ] up right i mean if you
lit a match
again in a day after the first candle
you lit you were like you went away for
25 years
and uh and that made that was weird to
me and then i was like oh it probably
makes sense because everything because i
do extra thinking right i'm not the kind
of guy that's like what why i do extra
thinking so i was like well back then
they didn't have fire retardant [ __ ]
probably if you let you know what i mean
if you lit a match you'd have to be like
say goodnight gracie
so
so i was watching this thing and it's
crazy what it's become like broadmoor
became this thing where they were very
like if you were criminally insane you
would just get put in this hospital it
was a hospital now that doesn't mean
that it wasn't like
better than a prison but apparently it
was kind of better than prison because
they would like try and treat you and
make sure that you were trying to get
better i mean even still you were
getting like
extreme and thrown at you because of
other crazy people in your [ __ ] ward
like they had five people to a room
but like still like you would like try
to do i mean yeah they did try to do
electro shock therapy and all that stuff
which made a lot of people [ __ ]
really
i mean it worked a little bit and also
didn't work it was a bad pr move for
[ __ ] for for mental health let's put
it that way for for the world of psycho
for the science of psychology and [ __ ]
it was a bad pr move right hey let's
electrocute people's brains and have
them bite their tongues off and [ __ ] it
seems very bad but apparently it worked
a lot
and then [ __ ] uh what's it called
came along one flew over the cuckoo's
nest came along and just [ __ ] that all
up
but i'm saying like you know some
comatose people would come in and they
wouldn't even know that who they were or
where they were and then you shocked the
[ __ ] out their brains and then they'd
wake up and it'd be like oh [ __ ] time
for some tea
i'm like oh you know what tea is like i
love tea i just couldn't ever say it
right because i i didn't even know what
i was doing i didn't know where i was
i didn't know who i was
but now it's like it's all good can i
have some crumpets
and um
and they're like oh wow like why is
everybody throwing [ __ ] on me this is
this is absolutely mental and they go
out and they get like a job dude you
come in all like
they just go
and you were just like oh hello
i'm a productive member of society what
am i doing in here it's so clinical oh
you mentor
and then they'd leave and they'd [ __ ]
start a business
you know what i mean
oh well
i need a 401k
why is this [ __ ] on me
[ __ ] it's all oh what's going on these
keeps throwing [ __ ] this is not a way to
live and then chuck them back and then
throw you know what i mean you can make
people go back and forth
i like being cancelled because i can say
whatever i want now and um
but yeah so
they did that and then i watched that
and a lot of [ __ ] crazy people were
in there and then it became like this
sort of a guy and then it was like this
one dude [ __ ] i was just gonna say
something good now i can't remember what
it was but this one dude
escaped broadmoor
and just started killing people
like
like dude talk about a [ __ ] up talk
about a pr like i'd love to see a
[ __ ] like uh an hbo max series on
this
but like
one guy escaped broadmoor in like the
early 1900s and just immediately started
killing [ __ ] like it wasn't
like it was like it was a zombie
like a [ __ ] fast one in uh what was
that movie with is brad pitt where they
did fast zombies
is that one where he's a fat is that the
one with their fast i don't know
whatever the zombies are with their fast
they come out world war z and he's just
like yeah i'm all good i'm all good i
won't kill and everyone turns down the
[ __ ] closing cell block gunk closing
cell block dude and it was so long ago
that they didn't even know like about
how easy escaping was and i was watching
this documentary and it was literally
like and what he did what how how he
escaped was he jumped on the roof and
jumped over and you're just like oh oh
put a barbed wire hey get guards
but it was 1912 and we didn't know that
they just wouldn't leave
the guards in there themselves needed
electric electro [ __ ] therapy just
letting people leave watching him go
just like probably fine
shock those [ __ ]
got him
[Music]
and the dude just left and he was like
goodnight everybody and then left and
then hopped over and then immediately
just started killing [ __ ] and
it ripped through the headlines and now
broadmoor is like this [ __ ] has got
talk about bad pr they're shocking
people's brains and [ __ ] are
leaving just killing everybody
immediately
and now broadmoor is like back to this
[ __ ] people think it's this prison
now
it's just [ __ ] up dude
it's weird to think about these people
though how they grew up like dude you
think people
it's weird to think about like uh
these people who have deep issues like
it's it's so weird to think about like
of course doing what you do is your
fault if it's [ __ ] horrible but also
like
god damn dude
if it's a mental disorder then what
right
luck of the draw you were just born
[ __ ] up and then your mom like threw
you down some stairs or whatever the
[ __ ] it was
i don't know but yemen's in the middle
east and i knew and i know that
so um
so yeah i watched that thing on
broadmoor i don't remember where i was
going with that but it doesn't matter
dude
all it was all all i know honestly is
sometimes i get sad i got sad remember
on the way to the haha i was talking
about that and then i got [ __ ] s
i was at this what was i [ __ ] waiting
for
i was waiting for something i was in
beverly hills and i was waiting for
something to get done and i was by
myself
i was waiting for something i can't
remember but i stopped in this cafe oh
yeah cause i got to get sinus surgery i
told you that so i had to go [ __ ] get
a
a checkup on that make sure that
i don't know man they just milk you for
money you know they're like come back
we'll check on your nose and you're like
okay you're like 300 bucks you're like
okay is it okay no yeah we're stopping
the surgery oh okay
and then um i'm waiting because i got
there early i thought it was going to
take longer and i'm waiting i got the
earlier i pop in a [ __ ] cafe
you know because i that's how i do it
and i pop in a cafe
and i and i go to order you know i get
the four shots over over espresso right
or four shots over ice sorry
four shots over espresso eight shots and
um
and i go in and i [ __ ] order it
dude
and i [ __ ] turn around first of all
beverly hills is out of control okay
beverly hills is out of control before i
went into the thing there was a hit and
run before i went into the cafe there's
just like uh i just hear like a bunch of
women oh no oh oh oh
oh no oh oh where did he go
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] where
did he go oh
and then i see another woman walking
back with her phone quickly and she's
like i got him i got i got the plate i
got it
and i'm just like what
oh my god oh she oh she got it oh she
got it lisa got it what was it
he just [ __ ] mumps him up and i and i
this is how beverly you think that's
beverly hills all the women coming
together trying to band together finding
a [ __ ] hit and run and i look and
some guys side mirrors off
and uh this is the most beverly hills it
does so much commotion so i [ __ ] look
at somebody in the uh what do you call
it the um
the patio of the cafe i'm about to walk
into and i say
what happened was there a hit and run
dude this is what the [ __ ] lady does
to me she's eating with her friend she
literally goes like this
and i'm like
okay
so [ __ ] rude you know
like
just say yeah yeah i guess so i don't
know she just looked at me like
and i'm just like be a person though and
like it's fine it would be fine if i
never saw her ever be a person but she
was eating with a friend just like yeah
and so this and that and nancy and them
and then
and then that happened and i'm just like
oh i'm a piece of [ __ ] so i'm going to
get the cafe and like all this crazy
wacky [ __ ] was happening
and then um
i ordered the [ __ ] four shots and
then i turn around and i look at this
painting
this painting of like i don't know maybe
it's italy but these like children are
playing in this courtyard and like this
house is
you know looks like it was made in
[ __ ] 1700s or some [ __ ]
and i'm watching this painting and i'm
looking at the kids and the parents
playing and i'm just like
i literally am thinking nothing other
than
wow that looks beautiful like that looks
i'm not even thinking you know how like
sometimes you don't even think words
you're i mean sometimes you think words
right like somebody will bump in here
and you'll actually think the words like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] like i guess you
do that for you you don't have to think
words but you literally think for you
like wow what a piece of [ __ ] you think
those words like that red balls bouncing
across it like you're watching the
[ __ ] sesame street when they're
singing along and like
and you're like uh
and it just bounces across [ __ ] these
[ __ ] and um
and sometimes you don't
but i wasn't thinking even words right
like sometimes you get lost in a
beautiful [ __ ] land in your mind
and i'm looking at this painting and i'm
just like
half thinking these words like wow that
seems beautiful but it's more like oh
wow
like you know what i mean i'm just
feeling the words
does it even make sense you know it just
felt nice to get locked into that
picture and then i start thinking
actual words like
i should just like
[ __ ]
what if i lived there
i literally just thought what if i lived
there what if i just grabbed calvin
grabbed my fiancee grabbed my you know
some of my friends that want to go
probably none of them but i could
suggest it to them you know i could
throw out an evite hay move into this
spot in italy
you want to come be away from everything
get off of social media or maybe just be
on it but be on it just like and just be
private on it and just have [ __ ]
italians follow you and [ __ ] and just
follow some other italians maybe follow
one or two other people that i knew from
back in l.a or even new jersey when i
was growing up but that's it you know
maybe my roommate in [ __ ] when i went
to nyu for eight months maybe follow him
but that's it right and then all of a
sudden just my my feed would be italian
and [ __ ] i'm just thinking about this
[ __ ] you know
i'm just getting lost in this painting
like lost in this painting like it's a
bad movie you know you ever see a bad
[ __ ] independent movie where a guy's
like going through some [ __ ] or even
better a woman she's going through some
[ __ ] and then she just looks at a
painting or looks at her reflection in a
[ __ ] side
in the side of a building the mirror and
she just like gets lost in it or even
worse the scene where the guy is in the
bar
and he's dealing with issues and he goes
into the bar and [ __ ] turns on the
water and
and pushes it up into his face and he's
[ __ ] like rinsing off his face like
have you ever done that like that's the
[ __ ] most
not the thing that's the most symbolic
only in movies thing ever that ever
happened
but i'm doing a version of that i'm
getting lost in this [ __ ] painting
like i'm in some [ __ ] like i'm ethan
hawk in some [ __ ] movie
you know what i mean like i'm jeffrey
rush in a movie in 2005.
just getting lost in it there's a
mandolin playing over the score
but i'm literally lost in it and i'm
like oh man i and i start thinking that
would be [ __ ] nice dude
and then i hear
fun
[Music]
but i still hear the le the mandolin i'm
like
[Music]
but i'm thinking about getting lost in
the courtyard and just i forgot it's a
little
shots over ice and i snap back into it
and i'm like oh yeah i'm just at this
[ __ ] cafe i witnessed a hit-and-run
and some shitty woman looked up at me
and gave me a death stare in goddamn
beverly hills
so i go oh yeah that's me i go over to
grab my [ __ ] four shots of espresso
and i take a sip and i look back at the
painting and now i'm back snap bang to
reality and i'm like
this is a [ __ ] fake place
i made up that it's in italy even
this may not even be a real this could
be some [ __ ] jerk off painting it
over in studio city above a starbucks in
his [ __ ] loft
that's you know what i mean
it's just a fake [ __ ]
i don't even know if this place existed
and then i leave the cafe and i'm like i
[ __ ] live here what do i do in being
an [ __ ] thinking i'm [ __ ] jeffrey
ross in some
mandolin ass score
uh
uh
[ __ ] independent movie that was
directed by like [ __ ]
jeffrey rush
and i'm like and i go to my nasal
appointment and the doctor's like yeah
yeah your walls are still [ __ ] up in
there yeah we gotta yeah you gotta do
the surgery and i'm like what am i doing
dude
you know you ever do that you ever get
lost in a painting
the fantasy is [ __ ] right like sometimes
it's
you're driving to the haha and you
[ __ ] think oh i'm sad for no reason
and then you think i'm gonna get burgers
[ __ ] it that's what's gonna make me
happy and then sometimes you just get
lost in a painting
because some woman was shitty to you on
a patio
but we're always trying to deal with our
[ __ ] i'm always trying to deal with my
[ __ ] and you know like three years ago i
would never try to deal with my [ __ ]
[ __ ] would just happen and i would just
keep moving dude
i just keep moving dude
it's hard as [ __ ]
it's hot as [ __ ] but it's fine i wore
the [ __ ] airy t-shirt right cause the
summer's coming i wore the [ __ ] airy
t-shirt that i used to wear all the time
and god damn i [ __ ] sure do like it's
crazy with the chains like that just
dropping over that [ __ ] look at that
[ __ ] dude looking crazy good dude look
how sexy that is just with the change
just dropping over just carelessly
dropping over the [ __ ] t-shirt and
also one of them's not even dropping
over the t-shirt it's just kind of like
laying across my [ __ ] great chest
dude it's insane how [ __ ] just
lackadaisical that looks how beautifully
[ __ ] ridiculously casual dude i'm
ridiculously casually sexy with that man
if i was walking on the street and
someone saw me like that they'd go like
this okay wow and they wouldn't even
realize it man these chicks need a towel
when i walk by with the ridiculously
[ __ ] scooped out casual [ __ ]
change just [ __ ] being ridiculous
over the goddamn thing i mean jesus
christ dude but whatever we don't really
think about it but when we [ __ ] have
it oh my god dude it's suddenly you
think god damn he really pulls it off
doesn't he but he didn't mean to but did
he though but did he right and he's got
the chest here peeking out like this
like it's a [ __ ] meerkat right the
chest hair is peeking out just just
peeking the [ __ ] out of the shirt oh but
also it's peeking the [ __ ] out of that
second chain isn't it too right
and it's trying to join look at it just
trying to [ __ ] just trying to join
just trying to join right there just
trying to join under my chin because he
keeps it [ __ ] at a 10 o'clock shadow
because that's super sexy too and the
grays the salt and peppers are keeping
it nice and he doesn't even have him in
his beard but they're trying to join
right they're trying to join like
spider-man in the [ __ ] marvel
universe but he can't because he's owned
by disney dude
my chest is spider-man trying to [ __ ]
join the marvel universe and we got thor
and hulk and we even got black widow up
in this [ __ ] over on my cheeks but
spider-man's come on like come on let me
play dude let me play but he's just got
to relax there he's just got to relax
there and be nice with the chains
doesn't he dude just peeking out like a
meerkat
and don't even let get me started on my
pubes that's [ __ ] moon night
what i want to know is speaking of these
[ __ ] universe movies and i mean this
i sincerely want to understand what the
[ __ ] i i sincerely
i i want i want answers and i want them
now in the co i actually want them in
the can could you guys comment
because i want to know
and i want to know this from like the
bottom like if i was a detective on the
police force i would be like sorry i
gotta work on this even though it's not
a crime
uh because we need to get to the bottom
of this because
um i this question has been burning for
a few days now
how
[ __ ] good
can top gun
be
okay
how good can it [ __ ] be though right
genuinely
how good can it be
because oh no but i hear oh but i get it
but i hear you though
but it's top gun right oh but it's not
even the original but i hear you though
and the original was good and even if
you walked back now yeah you do realize
how corny it is but for the time but
okay and i'm killed with that argument
but the new one though
now i haven't seen it but i want to know
though
how good can it [ __ ] be though
it's still top gun
the new one and yeah i get it there's
some new stars popping up you got the
guy with the toothpick in his mouth and
the black guy that i always think is
[ __ ] uh you know uh what's his name
son but it's not and it's fine am i
racist but all good but how good can it
be though
tom cruise is in it right and it's got
97 on rotten tomatoes and also hundred
percent on the rotten tomatoes and it's
like okay but how good can it be though
and rotten tomatoes [ __ ] sucks by the
way and i'll tell you this ron tomato
sucks and also the last time i heard a
movie was unbelievably good i saw it
shang ji or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called
oh
oh and it's [ __ ]
oh oh
oh oh and it's [ __ ] oh oh
oh
oh i saw shang ji because of the 97 on
rotten tomatoes oh but i saw it though
and yeah oh and the guy is a superstar
okay oh look out we've got a new asian
superstar oh and i saw it and i saw it
though but i sat in my living room and i
watched the whole things and
oops
right because of how [ __ ] uh
horrible it was
because of how [ __ ]
much of a [ __ ] stain on cinema it was
so you're gonna make me watch top gun
okay and my friends dude
i got people like eric griffin who yeah
loves bitch-ass movies
and i got people like my other friend
who's this [ __ ] cool ass dude yeah he
likes captain america's civil war
[Music]
but he [ __ ] loved top gun and i got
people posting it all up in my algorithm
about how it's actually really good
but how good can it be though
i've seen the trailer
it can't be as good as everyone's saying
so i'm gonna watch it
i'm gonna watch it
but i mean dude this whole 97 on rotten
tomatoes is and people act like it's
actually oh but it's the audience score
bro it's the people are voting for the
movies they like they're not voting for
the movies they don't like that's why
shang ji has 797 because every asian on
the planet is like finally our turn
and just [ __ ] put
you know what i mean or people are
feeling [ __ ] white guilt and they're
like well okay they gotta have theirs
dude it's terrible
it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] sucking bad
like yeah i get glenn powell's a nice
guy and i'm happy for him but come on
bro like is it that good
um
anyway
dude you know me man always trying to
search for the best [ __ ]
trimmer right because i trim
i always trim the cleaning ladies come
and they leave and then i trim and
kristen's like you always do it on the
[ __ ] cleaning lady and i'm like
you're right i do i really have a
[ __ ] that's so shitty i do that you
know i don't know what it is i think
it's because i want to shave on a
[ __ ] i want to trim on a clean
area
you know
i think maybe subconsciously that's what
it is but i'm being a real piece of [ __ ]
sometimes i make her sound like why are
you doing she's not like that she's the
sweetest angel in the world but like
that's just for comedic i guess or in my
head in memory that's how i want to
think about it because i don't want to
be wrong
[Laughter]
but um
so i got one and then it fell and then
it broke and i had to get it again dude
i don't even know how many shavers i've
[ __ ] bought in my life but
i got it again and then i [ __ ]
you know i keep it nice and i mean and i
keep it nice and i just did it and i'm
like [ __ ] yeah dude i keep it nice and
i'm not breaking this one
and i'm keeping it clean dude right like
i'm not the kind of guy who [ __ ] uses
the liquid to clean the shaver like what
a piece of [ __ ] but like i'm the kind of
guy that like tucks it away and wraps it
up a little bit and puts it in the
[ __ ]
thing right
and i'm playing with calvin
and then
you know how sometimes you hear sounds
that are not for the area that you hear
that you're in right
like here's the greatest example right
if you're in an ikea and all of a sudden
you hear
a bear growl
immediately everyone goes what the [ __ ]
is that but then
sometimes you hear sounds
uh that you might hear
close to the area you're in
and they're happening for a bit
and they don't shock you because it's a
familiar sound in an area where you
might be close to
and you don't realize the sound's
happening until later because you're
like wait a minute i know that sound and
it sounds familiar but why is it in this
area
like if you're
in a flower shop
and you hear
a truck backing up
but it's too loud and too close
you'll
might let that fly for like 20 seconds
and be like oh wait a minute where is
this [ __ ] thing and then you open the
back door and it's literally right
outside you're like okay i thought that
was weird right
so i'm playing with calvin and i realize
i've been listening to
my shaver going off
for like a minute and i i try to like
check i'm like
does this been going on how long has
this been going on i can't ask calvin
right because he's just like will you
smell de la men
smell the yemen
smell the yemen again i fro the yemen
yeah it does i put the yemen in the
tashkan and i'm just like you know
okay
but i'm listening to this
[Music]
and i'm like but that is happening i
guess but i'm in the living room
but like the room next to me is
the tv room
and that's my shaver i think but like
who's shaving in either the living room
or the tv room
nobody because the hair would be getting
all the
right
so i say kevin give me one second uh
let's take a break from selling this
yemen uh i have to walk over and see
and i look
and this is not a joke this is real life
you might be like oh but it's a joke and
you're a comedian
and the reason you might think that is
because it's a ridiculous thing to be
having happening but it's real
this is a documentary if cameras were
around this would be in a dramatic
documentary
kristin
is
shaving
the couch
the sentence i said
was the sentence i meant to say
kristen
is
shaving
the couch
you know that thing family sit on
she's shaving it
[Music]
and i look at
anyone
but the only other person is there is
calvin and he's smelling the yemen so
i'm like okay never mind
and she looks up to me and she says
i'm shaving the couch
and i say
what
what
and she says it's a really good idea
and i say
what and she says it's really working
and i say
what are you
using my shaver on the couch for and she
says look and she points
and the part she was shaving
looked
a lot cleaner than the part she wasn't
shaving
and i said
what's on there and she said there's dog
hairs on here that we don't even realize
[Laughter]
and i'm like
okay so this is how you're getting the
she's like yeah i tried doing it with
the scissors and tape and this is just
much better
and i'm like looking at her shaving the
couch i'm looking back at calvin
smelling a lemon 900 times and i'm just
like oh
i'm in broadmoor
oh
oh oh i'm a nurse in broadmoor
because everyone hears crazy but me
and i have to deal with it
just mean
shaving a couch i i throw the yemen yeah
like this it's yet i throw the yemen
yeah like this
i put the yemen in the taschen dada
smell the yemen and she's just shaving
it
it's a lime
just oh everyone okay all right and i
thought i was the crazy one
the day in the life my babies a day and
a lot a day in a life i know right
a day in a [ __ ] life
um
so i don't know what the [ __ ] to do
anymore what i do know is i'm not going
to see [ __ ] uh
top gun in the movie i'm gonna wait till
i come streaming and then i'm gonna
watch it and streaming everyone's gonna
be like dude you have to see it in the
theater that's why i got the 97
if everyone saw it at home it would be
[ __ ] more like 82 percent
as well a days huh
let's watch this here
where the [ __ ] did it go i handed you a
[ __ ] dear
man let's not watch that
what's this actually oh bro have you
guys seen
um
[Music]
look at [ __ ]
instagram.com dj
khaled
what's up with this god did thing
so dumb you know oops i put jd khaled
wow jd khaled just some [ __ ] white
lawyer
hi i'm j.d khalid
jd khaled attorney at law
um
god did that stupid thing that dj khaled
it's all for the [ __ ] it's got to be
all for the
and i can't play it yes dude can't play
it because i'm not signed in don't know
my [ __ ] thing yeah yes dude let's go
to [ __ ]
let's go to [ __ ] uh instagram here dj
khaled
god dad
dude this guy is insane
wow
it breaks my heart
wow
they ain't believing us
god did
[Laughter]
you played yourself
to succeed you must believe
they ain't believing us
god dude
the smurf they play themselves
wow
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know y'all
[Laughter]
the end of that how the end of that is
i've slept in days
like dude
get some sleep dude
hey you're [ __ ]
lucid you know
god dad imagine being so tired just
being so annoyed like the people around
him there's either this is the best part
there's either people around him or not
and either way it's horrible
what he's doing
looking in the [ __ ] thing showing his
pinky ring they ain't believing us it
breaks my heart they ain't believing us
god dead
and people are like can we just
you know what i mean the people near him
yo yo khalid
chill um
you want to watch the [ __ ]
hold up
you believe in me
yep
let's it's your turn dude they're
playing sorry
i've slept in days so so
get get sleep you know need sleep gonna
die of sleep exhaustion of whatever it
is you know what i mean
let me guess you're hugging your pillow
put a slob all over your pillow while
really getting mileage with this hugging
the pillow thing you got the pillows
with the zippers on so you you flip the
wounds all over your face
i mean now you're staying in the pillow
you know i mean you're sleeping all day
you know and then you get up then you
still complain
you know i mean even when you up you
look like you're you just been hugging a
pillow your face is permanently turned
into a pillow of it
it's so bad
tourette's
tourette's special
makes no sense there
makes no sense there dude
let me guess you'll be
let me guess man like worst worst game
show let me guess you're hugging your
pillow
wrong
wrong the answer was john f kennedy
let me guess let me guess you got
zippers on your pillow
[Music]
no no it was the alamo
god dad can we remove him please
i mean dude it breaks my heart
dude this guy it's like it's like who's
trying to be more
more like rick ross him or rick ross oh
here he's sitting on a speaker
the most annoying
in the world dude sitting on a speaker
with a noise [ __ ] maker do it or
whatever the [ __ ] those things are
called
where is it
wait where is it hold on
[Music]
oh that's it that's the whole that's the
whole thing wow
how much did you think that was a toilet
and he was [ __ ] on it
god did
here's another one
oh there's no sound on this one okay
hold on oh god wait i don't want to play
that one
oh here we go
i wear my sneakers just focus on the
sneakers today
focus on the sneakers go ahead and focus
on the sneakers
[Applause]
that guy's fired
that heat immediately with miami heat
gain
because you know we all about that heat
we wear the heat wow bring the heat so
not create the surgery so i'm not
creating sand
coming a little closer
you need to watch because it's always on
time
pick up saudi
you know i mean pick up palestine the
whole middle east
you know what i mean yep i get to walk
oh
get the
all
walk
oh my god dude now get to watch because
it's always on time not good you know
not necessarily not something to brag
about now get the watch get the shoes
they on my feet
hell yeah
get the hair it's growing
so
[ __ ] not
creative got the heat on my feet and
going into miami heat
um dj khaled is an insane person but you
know it's probably all for the [ __ ]
instagram
um
god dad
wow it's so funny that he's been married
for so long too
like that's the most hilarious part
this was great man what a great episode
dude beer
let's have one
um
so uh these are my dates in my cities
where i'm gonna be my babies i'm gonna
be [ __ ] crazy places uh i mean it's
insane gonna be in lake is it lake
lakeland florida going to be in uh grand
prairie texas which is the dallas play
go to crystalia.com that's the new one
that's gonna be on tour i don't know if
we need the
pre-sale code which is uh
don't push me probably
i i don't know when this is going up it
might not be up yet when this
episode comes out so don't be mad at me
but it is coming atlanta georgia
september 9th almost sold out washington
dc almost sold out stockton california
oakland california peoria illinois
rockford illinois all of those are going
to be september and october raleigh
north carolina october 21st october 22nd
savannah georgia denver colorado
november 5th at bellco theater
huge spot
uh cheyenne wyoming november 6th
boston two shows
on november 12th
the early one in the late one at the
wang theater
crazy tickets jacksonville florida um
december 3rd go get those tickets uh
they're selling out and uh go to
crystalia.com check out that new [ __ ]
life absolutely riffs get that puffed
out [ __ ] you want to be puffed out um
hey guys uh that's it for the youtube
episode uh if you want to join uh the
patreon and catch the rest of the
episode the uncut episode crystal or
sorry patreon.com it's
patreon.comcrystalia
uh there's i think 14 episodes uh
of only patreon only episodes go binge
them right now dude that [ __ ] is
breaking bad but we appreciate you guys
either way and uh
patreon.com thanks
[Music]
you